i'm tammy bruce and for the week we are
taking you inside the left's playbook
exposing not just their rampant
corruption
but the method to their madness we will
highlight the heroes in this fight
and prove to you how we can and will
prevail
tonight the extreme left is unleashing
what is now the most dangerous
diabolical
and destructive power grab in modern
political history
as the democrats along with their
enablers in the media have made clear
they are ready willing and able to do
whatever it takes to grab power
never give up and inflict on everyday
americans what would be an
unprecedented amount of control and
coercion
over our everyday lives but ask yourself
how did we get to this point
we're packing the supreme court open
borders d.c statehood
and even hating and abolishing the
police became part of the mainstream
political dialogue
how is it that the same cabal of
entrenched washington democratic
fixtures
the same ones who lectured us on trump's
supposed threats to
institutional integrity are now the ones
looking to upend
the separation of powers overhaul our
structure of government
make our cities less safe all while
clinging
to the power at all costs the answer is
actually simpler
than you think what the left accuses the
rest of us of doing
is always exactly what they are doing
themselves no no no don't you dare look
at them of course
look away at their distractions they
don't care about being called hypocrites
they don't care about being accused of
double standards because it's all part
of their larger playbook
the end game for them is all about money
and power
and that means controlling the narrative
because if you control the narrative
control the language and definitions and
control the framing
you've won remember they accused
president trump of russia collusion for
four
long years when in reality it was
hillary clinton
and the dnc who paid christopher steele
who then used russian sources
to put together the debunked
disinformation dossier
and over the last year democratic
governors accused republicans
of wanting to kill grandma and grandpa
for daring to question the ever-evolving
proclamations
of so-called public health bureaucrats
all the while
blue state governors like andrew cuomo
put sick patients into nursing homes
actually killing thousands of
grandparents and got caught trying to
cover it up
ironically in the end it was people like
hillary
cuomo biden harris the lincoln project
swalwell pelosi and waters among so many
others
who were the miscreants and the
scoundrels they accused trump of being
and it was the hollywood machine that
protected sexual predators
like harvey weinstein for years while
lecturing the rest of us
about the sins of sexual harassment and
the abuse of women
all while spewing woke virtue signal
jargon
in our direction seemingly every hour of
every day
did you hear any apologies or admissions
of culpability at last night
last night's oscars but of course you
weren't watching neither was i
but uh they they didn't instead they
delivered the most
woke oscars ever they couldn't even
control themselves for two minutes
and what was the theme for this group of
people who were likely relying on police
protection
to enjoy their night of backslapping and
self-reverential congratulations
hating and bashing police officers we'll
deal with this unacceptable attack
on american heroes in detail tonight but
not all liberals
actors and creatives have surrendered to
the woke mob
some have even taken the lead in
confronting it rose mcgowan is one of
those heroes
she joins us later tonight for her first
in-depth interview on fox
news but we are now living in a moment
where seemingly every major
institutional
power center is taking its marching
orders from the left
big tech big business entertainment
education
from grade school to college along with
most of the media
gleefully parrot democratic lies fuel
hyperbole
and spu vicious rhetoric all to
needlessly divide us
the american people but is there
anything democrats are doing to actually
improve
the quality of anyone's lives other than
their own
the agenda of black lives matter the
marxist group certainly isn't making
communities safer
as homicides spike across the country
three people were killed and 22 others
wounded in shootings across chicago this
weekend
there were nearly two dozen shootings
across new york city this weekend
hate crimes against asians and the
jewish community continue to plague the
progressive big apple
censorship from big tech does nothing to
strengthen our democracy in fact it does
the opposite
and reckless immigration policy harms
poor americans first
and erodes trust that our leaders will
faithfully execute
the laws of the land but don't you worry
while they're releasing covet 19
infected immigrants into the interior of
the country
migrant children get to read kamala
harris's kids book
it's included in what can only be called
a welcome pack
given to unaccompanied minors at the
border propaganda
aimed even at children so ask yourself
can you name
any policy from the left if implemented
that will enhance the lives of working
people
when we walk out our doors tomorrow we
know who those toxic
ideas will hurt the most even if our
leaders in washington
don't seem to care it's why the america
first
populist agenda is more important than
ever and why it's not
enough to simply shout hypocrisy or
double standards
because what we are up against is beyond
bias
it is beyond just a difference of
opinion there is now a full-blown
far-left propaganda machine that has
infiltrated the most powerful
institutions
on the globe hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else